first up she is President Obama's former
UN Ambassador and a poet surprise
winning author whose new book is the
education of an idealist a memoir
Samantha power there's so many
interesting things about you I'm gonna
start at the beginning which is you're
an immigrant to this country from the
country where my ancestors were
immigrants from Ireland you still got a
bit of a Brogue I bet I when I got to
this country yeah you do I loved abroad
when I when I came it was not a
political act to be an immigrant
it wasn't controversial we arrived we
were welcomed and I moved to Pittsburgh
when I was nine from Ireland and I did
have a thick Dublin accent and I put big
league chew in my mouth and fell in love
with baseball and imitated all my
neighbors and I worked on losing my
American accent so I could fit in and
became a big sports fan and I figured
that was the League of lingua franca in
this country and dedicated myself to
that and probably would be a
sportscaster today but while I was once
taking notes on an Atlanta Braves game
as an intern the freshman year my
freshman year in college I saw the
footage from Tiananmen Square and the
tanks kind of rolling over young people
my age and 30 years ago maybe maybe
maybe I should and that's when you
became war cars that's because you were
a war correspondent I I wish I mean as
Epiphanes work you tend I think in your
as you remember them you think you had
some grand epiphany and you decides
decided I was gonna become a human
rights lawyer and change the world and
be UN ambassador someday but in fact I
just said to myself I need to watch less
sports study a little bit and figure out
what the hell's going on in the world
and so I went back to college and I
worked at it and then just as I
graduated I had another one of those
kind of moments and I opened up the
newspaper and there were concentration
camps in Europe 50 years after the
Holocaust ruin it was that that made me
think the Balkans something I can do I
tried to be an aid worker I had no
skills and I had covered the women's
volleyball and you were very critical of
the
America and that really got the
attention of somebody you have a lot in
common with which is the man you worked
for a Barack Obama I mean you both lived
in a few different countries when you
were little right yeah I mean it was
troublesome father a very enlightened
mother who was ahead of her time I never
thought of those those parallels yeah
quite that number of parallels but
definitely I mean one of the things that
drew me to him and maybe him to my
writing was the ability to see America
from the inside and push American
interests but also to be able to step
back and say what do we look like also
to others do we have credibility do we
have legitimacy how can we build that
store of capital so we can draw on it
when we need it I know you say and this
course is in a joking way but he used to
say I'm glad you're in the room because
it's good to have your voice to find out
what values we are betraying today and
he meant that in a funny way but it's
interesting because like the song says
you kind of seen life from both sides
now from first you were a critic on the
outside and then you said wait I can be
on the inside and maybe do some good but
of course on the inside you have to make
compromises nothing gets done without
some sort of compromises and that was
difficult for you yeah I mean it was an
adjustment certainly but I felt as a
reporter I was waiting for somebody to
read my articles or I'd write an
editorial about something we should do
and I was hoping somebody in power would
do something about it in government you
just get to try to push the agenda you
have and I my values were aligned so
much with President Obama's he was
trying to build global coalition's to
deal with threats you know to our people
but also he was trying to promote human
rights where we could recognizing the
limits of our influence but also
recognizing that sometimes we
underestimate how much we can achieve so
I mean the hardest was it was a little
bit like moving to America and I write
this in the book that it when I got into
government suddenly people were using
all these horrible gendered metaphors
you know they say when we go into this
negotiation we got to go in open kimono
I'd be like open kimono okay yeah I
never heard that this is like there's a
whole bureaucratic Lane
but but there was a lingo there was
learning how to build coalitions I mean
you know I've written a book called the
education of an idealist and it suggests
the arc you know would be one from
idealism to realism but landing it at
the UN I mean the UN you you could not
find a place that was in a way more
inappropriate for an idealist what what
is more compromise than the UN I mean
right now on the Human Rights Council
there are six dictators including that
madmen in the Philippines Duarte yeah
six new ones there are actually a few
who were on from prior terms so there's
even more than six yeah look it's Iran
is on the woman's Council yeah it's how
do you square that circle well again let
me say that in my time at the UN I
became more not less idealistic so bear
with me it is compromised on one level
in the sense that there are more non
democratic countries in the world than
democracies and they comprise the global
institution that is the UN so there 193
countries and we know very fair question
we are I mean the most backsliding that
is happening right now in the world is
within established democracies like this
one and the writ freedom is in decline
but it's also a venue to challenge those
countries in terms of their treatment of
women or in terms of their inability to
deal with extremism in their midst and
to urge them to do more or their or
they're looking the other way from the
recruitment of child soldiers and other
things one of the concepts that I tried
to introduce to my team was the idea of
shrinking the change because even when
you're in the government and you're in
the cabinet of the president United
States as I had the privilege of being
you feel small next to the abusiveness
of these governments or the refugee
problem the seventy million people who
are displaced today or the warming
planet but it was really important in
both at the White House and at the UN
it's really important for me now as a
citizen to think okay what is the narrow
slice of this problem that I can
actually do something about so I can't
deal with the freedom recession around
the world or the backsliding as a whole
but let me see if I can get twenty
female political prisoners out of jail
right weren't you know and build a
coalition and the person who is there
now Trump's appointee somebody named
Kelly Kraft she was a big Republic
donar no it's it's not unusual to
appoint a Republican or a Democratic
donor but usually do it to some
ambassadorship where it's not a big deal
but UN yeah call magnet she believes
there are good scientists on both sides
of the climate debate so I guess my
question is I you know this is a week
when we're talking or I'm gonna be
talking a lot about the Stooges that
Trump has put in place and we see this
now with what's going on with the
whistleblower scandal somebody at the
head of the DNI is headed it looks to me
like a stooge bill Barr plainly is that
what about the UN what about the
diplomatic core is that hollowed out how
deep is the deep state I keep as well I
can say that one of the things that
happened after Trump was elected and it
was shocking to many people but you can
imagine the people on my team who helped
negotiate the Paris agreement or the
Iran nuclear deal or minorities or
people with disabilities people but you
know classes of people who've been
attacked by the candidate Trump they
were it was an incredibly disparate
event for some of them and yet they all
resolved to stay basically to serve our
country the career foreign service outro
the career civil service servants but
they found themselves so marginalized
held in such contempt at the highest
level and and the key is that expertise
is not valued you know when everything
is deemed an opinion and when science
isn't valued and when language expertise
our having lived in a country isn't held
in high regard it's been very hard for
those people to stay so the hollowing
out is real and part of what's going to
need to happen if a Democrat when the
Democrat is elected to replace the
current president
who are skeptical of government and
skeptical of our ability to do good are
going to have to come and be part of the
recovery we are going to have to rebuild
institutions that have been ravaged and
Obama's foreign policy doctrine was
famously summarized as don't do stupid
[ __ ] Trump's of course is too stupid
should do a lot of stupid [ __ ] as
quickly as possible
what what should what should a liberal
foreign policy doctrine be well I think
it starts with the strength of our
democracy at home which is our
number-one priority
it starts with strengthening our
democratic institutions not attacking
the media not attacking judges not
attacking minorities obviously when we
when we have a democracy that is the
envy of the world and we've always had
major issues at home of course but we've
still been a bit of a light and a lot of
people around the world would love to
have the freedoms that many of us get to
enjoy here so starting there that's our
foundation remembering that values are
our comparative advantage especially
when China's rising in the world and
there really are going to be two
competing models and understanding that
there are very few threats to Americans
that don't require global solutions that
don't require teamwork and cooperation
that doesn't mean the use of military
force which has been overused our
foreign policy now we have soldiers
active in counterterrorism activities of
some kind in more than 40% of the
countries in the world and that
militarization is not sustainable it's
not fair to those soldiers and and we
have to change that but at the same time
US leadership is critical if we're going
to catalyze the solutions that we need
to the things that really matter
especially to young people well it's a
fascinating book I hope you get back in
the game
[Music]
[Applause]
you